hey I've got a documentary
recommendation for you this is one of
the most amazing documentaries I've seen
because of how disturbing it is it's
called trophy kids you might have heard
the term trophy wives this is trophy kid
this is about parents who are pushing
their kids outrageously to participate
in sports and the film follows there's
two basketball dads there's a football
dad a tennis mom of twins and a golf dad
one is crazier than the ones in the next
than the last however the phrase goes
the tennis mom is particularly mentally
ill for sure she has actually like a
Christian biblical approach to her
trophy kid parenting it's insane I mean
these you can see the damage that is
being suffered by these kids at the
hands of their parents pushing them in
this way to participate in sports I
could not put it into words you just
have to see it yeah it's like they're
pushing their kids to become the next
professional athlete in that sport and
the biggest and greatest thing but I
mean for the most part most people
aren't going to grow up to be
professional athletes and then you
shouldn't push them in that direction
you know when you you will see if you
watch the documentary that the sole
focus of the lives of these children at
the demand not the request at the demand
of their parents is total focus on one
particular sport where realistically and
as it becomes clear throughout the
documentary the odds of ever becoming a
professional in the sports that the
parents are pushing these kids to to
participate in are very very low right
what are the odds that just because you
have your kid play football from the
time that he's little he's going to make
it into the NFL the odds are still not
very high same thing applies with the
NBA and you're depriving your child of
just reasonable well-rounded
participation in different areas of life
I would not argue I'm not saying this
but if someone saw the movie and then
they said this is child abuse I wouldn't
argue against that I think there's a
case to be made for that people push
their kids towards sports to teach them
things like teamwork working together
not to be a sore loser I'll rot or less
these nice lessons yes and for the most
part I mean coming becoming a
professional athlete has to do with your
size
your natural talent and you know at all
the training and stuff is on top of that
it's two things together and you can
only control one of them right and and
there's no doubt about that this
documentary is trophy kids you can check
this out along with all of my other
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations on the bonus show
today the fda is warning your pacemaker
could get hacked we will talk about
demand with tree branch hands who can
now see his fingers and GMO related
story david pakman.com slash membership
that's the one place where you can sign
up for membership next Friday on Donald
Trump's inauguration day we will be
emailing out through our mailing list a
major David Pakman show membership
discount if you want to be notified
about that sign up for our newsletter at
david pakman.com just put in your email
address in the next friday you'll be
notified about this huge membership
discount